termino en la ciudad de cali aquí en
colombia el mundial de atletismo sub 20
una vitrina para conocer el presente y
futuro de este deporte para analizar
estas justas me acompaña nuestra
periodista de la reacción el martes a
experta en la materia ahora una
bienvenida un placer lograr vamos a
comenzar hablando de este mundial eeuu
terminó como campeona pero nos vamos a
centrar en las estrellas internacionales
que brillaron en la velocidad que es lo
que casi que más está hablando de este
mundial que destacamos el de ese mundo
sub-20 a ver los dos récords mundiales
que se rompieron en el mundial sub-20
fueron en velocidad estamos hablando del
991 de leche leche élite vogue o en los
100 metros planos y además el 3 17 69
del relevo de jamaica y creo que hay que
destacar la velocidad femenina de
jamaica para digamos poner el acento
sobre lo que fueron las distancias
cortas en este campeonato mundial ese
relevo reunía a la campeones la
subcampeona de los 100 metros tiene a
clayton
serena col además a qué rica gel que
ganó los 100 metros con vallas y la
gemela de tina clay tía clay pero además
de todo se queda por fuera sin correr
este relevo la ganadora de los 200
metros que desvían al listón y eso nos
habla de la profundidad que tiene la
velocidad femenina de jamaica que lleva
tres mundiales juveniles consecutivos
ganando los 100 metros viana y la
profundidad y el relevo la capacidad de
crear nuevas jornadas de jóvenes nuevas
generaciones porque recordemos que en el
mundial de 2018 es mucho se hablaba de
dónde podría llegar bryant a williams
finalmente no terminó la explosión en la
categoría adulta pero de inmediato al
siguiente mundial juvenil ya tienen a
una tina clayton
dominando la distancia otra cosa que
destacar dentro del tema de la velocidad
es el caso de los chiles de bobo en el
masculino y de la misma tiene a clayton
que no es muy común que un juvenil
renueve o
le repita su campeonato ellos fueron
campeones el año pasado les tocaba
correr en 2020 no se corrió por la
pandemia y se rueda este mundial hasta
2021 en el pasado el de nairobi y
repiten en esta oportunidad los dos su
campeonato eso es algo que no se da
regularmente
en esta categoría que se caracteriza
sobre todo por la renovación los 200
metros masculino también es importante
destacar el hecho de que blessing
acuesta cuasi áfrica el chico de origen
guineano que corre por israel que gana y
el lecce élite burgos se convierten en
los únicos dos sub 20 de la historia que
corren por debajo de 20 segundos en la
misma prueba
y 1996 definió 6 milésimas de segundo la
diferencia entre ellos dos entonces creo
que todas estas cosas marcan marcan
historia dentro de este mundial no tiene
200 o muy rápidos los que tuvimos el mar
que podemos destacar acerca de la
participación latinoamericana es que
tuvimos en este mundial sub-20 de cali
fundamentalmente colombia esas tres
medallas que gana colombia el único oro
lo consigue méxico en la marcha o en la
prueba donde que es realmente muy
tradicional para méxico pero colombia
tuvo dos medallas de plata la de
valentina barrios en la jabalina también
el relevo 4 por 400 4% gana la medalla
de bronce y la otra plata era de una de
las favoritas o la que siempre cargó con
el favoritismo para subir al podio en
esta oportunidad que es natalia linares
otra cosa que vale la pena destacar para
américa latina es el dominio en el salto
largo y en la jabalina porque dos de los
tres
ocupantes del podio son latinoamericanos
en el salto largo la plata la gana el
cubano alejandro parada y el bronce
gabriel bolsa de brasil en la jabalina
la plata la gana valentina barrios de
colombia y el bronce es la primera
medalla de la historia para uruguay en
un campeonato mundial juvenil uruguay
tenía medallas mundiales en categorías
sub-18 en la categoría cadete que ya no
se disputa en el atletismo mundial pero
no lo había logrado nunca en en la
categoría junior y lo logra a través de
manuela rotundo buenas noticias para los
nuestros entonces en este mundial
dejamos del mundial sub20 de cali pero
hablamos de la ley de amante que poco a
poco entra en su recta final tuvimos
cita en silesia en polonia vamos a sacar
a dos figuras sobre todo si una de ellas
indudablemente shelly ann fraser pryce
que sigue redondeando un año mágico y
eso se dice fácil pero cuando uno piensa
que tiene 35 años que incluso pasó por
un parón de un año para
para tener a su bebé para cumplir su
fase de maternidad eso digamos que cobra
más relevancia marca un 10 y 66 que se
convierte en un nuevo récord de
competencia para silencia pero además se
convierte en la mejor marca mundial del
año mejora ese 10 67 con el que había
impuesto un récord de campeonato hace un
par de semanas en oregón entonces
totalmente
destacable lo que logra esta atleta a
esta edad digamos pensar que está en el
mejor momento de su carrera con 35 años
es súper importante y lo otro es
totalmente lo contrario un joven recién
salido del juvenil que hace nada estaba
corriendo campeonatos mundiales
juveniles como alison dos santos que
viene de ser campeón mundial
hace dos semanas también en oregón gana
los 400 metros con vallas con récord de
competencia aún teniendo una serie final
muy lenta porque él termina imponiendo
el récord de competencia de 47 80 y
estuvo un segundo y medio por encima de
lo que fue su récord de campeonato
en oregón hace un par de semanas
entonces es
destacable el dominio que ha tenido de
los santos en los 400 metros con vallas
a tan corta edad que no nos hace augurar
un fenómeno como el terrible más rojas
en el salto triple que es un dominio
bastante largo porque estamos hablando
de un atleta de 23 años en la atleta
sumamente joven